i mean look for if we're going to talk
about bisexuality there really needs to
be two people in this conversation
[Laughter]
really
[Applause]
[Music]
the real kicker of it is i'm gonna leave
your reaction to that in the video
hey everybody so uh we're up to this
month's
uh conversation about um representation
of lgbtq plus characters in media and
as i have done at this point already
with asexuals and as i will do again
with
other sexualities uh and talking about
representation of a specific
sliver uh of that um whole rainbow
of options i have brought someone who
identifies as such so
most of you should know my partner liz
hi everyone
we're gonna talk about representation of
bisexuals
but yeah i suppose just like i think
most people know what bisexual means but
for the sake
of clarity let's define our terms do you
want it
i would say there are people who are
attracted to both
men and women possibly non-binary as
well
yeah i mean strictly speaking bisexual
means attracted to
two genders two genders now
typically that would be male and female
maybe it's
female and non-binary maybe it's you
know it could but the
textbook definition is that now that
said we are kind of gonna spill over a
little bit
into um pansexual
because i think there's a like a lot of
um
depictions don't really distinguish and
i
at least i don't think i'm gonna be able
to find enough
that is explicitly pansexual to be able
to devote
a video to just that and for the sake of
clarification
generally when people say pansexual what
that means is
the attraction is not determined by the
physical sexual characteristics of the
partner
they will they have an attraction to a
person and the physical mechanics are
incidental and they'll roll with
whatever that happens to be
there's also and we'll get to this with
at least one of the people we're going
to talk about there's also omnisexual
which is an active attraction to
virtually everything
it's more of a thing in fiction than it
is in reality but conceptually
pansexual is my attractions aren't
determined
by someone's physical sex
characteristics omnisexuals
my attractions are determined by your
physical sex characteristics but i find
all of them attractive
yeah so anyways i think that's enough i
really always feel a little
uncomfortable
trying to define things because i'm like
well
this is what i think the definition i
mean that's also the other a lot of
these are kind of fluid concepts and
terms but broadly speaking these are the
concepts as
as i understand them and i'm the one who
gave the definition so if you take issue
with the definitions come at me
i can take it leave her out of it i mean
i could probably take it too i just
you know i hesitate a lot of the time to
like because i think people
definitely whenever it's a very
important label for them or
identity for them defining it
you get into like a gray area fair
enough so i'm looking down
at how many pages of notes do you have
like it's like two in a bit okay
you're the one who did a heck of a lot
more research than i do i didn't do that
much research i just
i i just said more i just said a heck of
a lot more than i did
okay not a heck of a lot in a vacuum but
just a lot more than me
why don't we talk about some of the
tropes that come with bisexual
representation
when you're talking any representation
it tends to bring certain baggage and
certainly oh yeah and they're certain
tropes along with them
there's a lot of them um most of them
are not great
um so there's bisexuality where it's
there and represented in terms of for
male gaze or exploitation
ah yeah so these would be your instances
where pre it's pretty much
always a woman who is the bisexual in a
case like this
and it's always because a girl kissing a
girl is sexy
yeah so i mean even the song i kissed a
girl katy perry song
is a great example of that yeah no legit
and i always i almost hesitate to call
it bisexuality too
because it's it's it's there for well
that's specifically
i mean it's the male gaze yeah or
it's perpendicular performance is
performative by
sexuality yeah and it may or may not be
legitimate but the purpose of it either
from the person doing it or the
writer who wrote it in and the director
or whoever somebody is doing it
for the sake of a male audience um
regardless of how rooted it is
in reality ooh kind of yeah so like this
this is your um oh god i forgot what was
the
it was wild wild things i never said
denise richards and
yeah it's it's very much that or our
basic instinct
actually that'd be a really good fit for
that which works in another trope that
we'll get to as well
um oh yeah that is that one's a borges
sword
yeah yes um
so and i've never seen basic instincts
so if you have i'll let you talk more
about it but i know
enough about the character to place it
in various tropes
so um uh it happens
not frequently but it's happened a
couple times on teen shows
i would put on the oc marissa's brief
fling with a woman as an example of it
um there's
a kiss between the two main female
characters on riverdale in the first
season which is very much
um i'm a little surprised to hear
riverdale come up not because i've heard
amazing things about riverdale i haven't
but but because honestly that is one
that strikes me as one that we don't see
very much anymore
yeah because a couple years ago i was
kind of like really
yeah because that that's the kind of
thing that
but it was very much a performative kiss
and it wasn't necessarily
in front of the boys but it was a
performative and
it's on a teens show so i'm like yeah
okay i know what's going on here
yeah and they have had better
representations since then but
it was like it might have been the first
episode and i was like
oh that's a rough start yeah so i mean
but like i think
overall we don't see too much of that
sort of thing anymore because it is
so nakedly exploitative it gets it gets
called out pretty readily here so
unless i mean granted it's not a new
movie but unless you get something like
a basic instinct that is just so
reveling and being exploited by its
nature i don't think that's something
that you
see unironically anymore
um so let's let's go to the other thing
i put um is her name catherine the basic
instinct character i
think so just say sharon stone sharon
stone's character
um so the other trope that i put her in
for bisexuals
is um villains villainous characters
bisexual villains
is yeah that's kind of a big one
so i have not seen house of cards but
frank underwood would fall into that
barbara keane on gotham i love barbara
to death but yes
she does fit this bisexual
villain um oh yeah she fits it i read
articles where they talked about you
know like true blood and they talked
about oz
and yes they're villains but i also like
those shows kind of lend themselves to
villainous characters anyways whenever
you're talking about a vampire show
i mean those were there shows that are
inherently about
bad people that's like kind of the whole
thing yeah there's gonna be a lot of
moral great
uh like gray area anyways so i'm
kind of like yes you're
right but there's just gonna be a higher
percentage of
everyone is evil anyway so
i don't know so i'm i'm less apt to use
those
um but i mean talking about so talk
about the trope in general i think
part of this often comes down to the
fact that
um and i don't know if you have this on
your list of tropes but bisexuality
often comes with sort of a general
concept usually a misunderstanding
that it is a hedonistic instinct yeah i
have a whole category of promiscuity
which i had to like overflow as i
thought of more examples yeah
well i mean the promiscuity can be
handled by itself but i do think there
is a bleed over
between that and the villain elements
yes
i put them together for a reason yeah i
think the reason for that is like i said
i think there is a misconception
probably still fairly heavily that well
they're bisexual because they just can't
get enough from one gender so they go to
the other one as well or
and if you tie it to a hedonistic
instinct that's generally something
that's frowned upon so you're going to
tag that to a
villainous character and i think that's
that's a
fair part of what you see although i
think the femme fatale might almost be
its own thing where it's like
oh now we really can't trust this woman
because she's bisexual
oh yeah um
yeah so in that category of promiscuity
that's that's uh that's a lot of names
um
so we have oberyn and ellaria
on game of thrones yup kalinda on the
good wife who i
i really enjoyed her on the good wife
but she probably fits that trope
um you have beau um the main character
in lost girl
yep a converter from oh yeah who who
also can bleed
arguably into villains yeah yeah there's
a lot of bleed over
um i would say to a certain degree in
terms of literature
um shug avery um or chug avery
um from the color purple kind of fits in
there
i'm i'm a i'm not active i never read it
did they ever on will and grace do they
ever establish
karen as bisexual i hated that show so i
have no idea
i feel like she it might have been
heavily implied so we can put her in the
kind of
implied category as much as i think
she's a good representation there was
one point where rosa was dating a man
and a woman at the same time this is on
brooklyn nightline nine-nine
so like they she doesn't usually fall
into that category but i was like oh no
why did they do this well i mean and i
bring this up when i talk about tropes
in general
whenever you talk about a trope not
every single instance that a trope is
used
automatically makes it bad it's just
this sort of thing happens so much that
it becomes a problem so
just because someone like rosa who i'm
pretty sure
someone will bring up again when we talk
about more positive representation just
because
she also fits this at least in an
instance doesn't
suddenly discredit the character it just
means like
something to watch out for it even shows
up here other times it's usually worse
um and when you're talking about tv
shows you can look at a character over
several seasons
and different relationships and talk
about that um oh
and then i think i think helen in um
kissing jessica stein also would fit
into that category
it has been a long time since i've seen
that movie and i know you hate it so
i don't like it that is true i do like
helen's character though she is probably
my favorite part of that movie
um i don't like jessica much and i
really
don't like the guy that she ends up with
under this heading
there is a character i alluded to
earlier which is
captain jack harkness from doctor who
yeah
which cover that when i say alluded to
earlier under the omnisexual kind of
thing because it
while we only ever see him pair off
with humans we see him flirt and it is
made very clear that he has had
relations with
aliens and robots and like the
yeah the if it is sentient he will at
least flirt with it
that's kind of his thing now what is
interesting about him i think is for as
massive as his interests
seem to be that he is a an unambiguously
heroic character
because usually for someone with as
broad a taste as he has like i said
you'd get into the hedonistic thing
but he's played he's played for a little
bit more of a
sort of a lothario type and
he's not necessarily praised for that
but it is a bit of a
there he goes again and it just is with
whoever else happens to be
in the room like i think the doctor
actually points out and sometimes like
stop it all i did was say hello
for from you that's enough
yeah i he's a very well-loved character
so i never got the sense that it varied
into villainous territory no it didn't
and like as far as that specific aspect
of the character the show
even when he was on torchwood never
judged him for that
um the torchwood especially would
judge him for some of his actions in
some of his history
but never for that
[Music]
this whole concept of like you can't
like both genders at the same time you
can't
really be like it you you can be this
and now you can be this and you can date
men and now you're dating women but you
can't really like them both at the same
time so this
kind of gets into the whole notion of
bisexual erasure
which is a term that gets used in terms
of entertainment but is actually
kind of rooted in um medical and
scientific history
because there were lots of sexuality
studies where
literally they the studies and the
people holding it would not categorize
bisexual they would determine well who
are they with more
find them they're straight or they're
gay and there are literally decades
worth of research that is i don't want
to say invalid but
is half assed because the researchers
literally erased it now as as it applies
to entertainment
it's basically what you said so i think
like a really good recent example that
gets brought up
a lot is piper from
orange is the new black because when she
starts seeing a woman
the conversation is never oh she's
bisexual the conversation is
oh she's gay now or she's gay again
yeah it's it's it's this idea like
there's two sides and she has
she can be on one and then she flips and
she's on the other
because she starts out well i mean
obviously
she starts out before the series begins
with alex
yeah and then she's with i can't
remember the character's name
the her fiance who's male when the
series
starts yep and then she goes back to
alex and she i mean other females so
it's
but i don't think they ever define her
as bisexual
no they keep referring to her as gay or
straight
and that's always the it's it's always
dealt with as a binary
yeah really and in general i they don't
really
address bisexuality much on the show
i mean a lot of emotions i would like no
i mean
especially considering that they've got
ample room to do it and they're dealing
with enough
um you know uh
questionable stuff anyway like there's
no reason to avoid it
i know i see another name down there
that i know has come up when i've
when i brought it up in other videos and
that's willow
yeah i yeah i feel like
she was with us and i fee i think that
is a significant relationship but i also
get that
there are a lot of people who have you
know dated
men in high school and since then yeah
have been with ex
i'm willing to say i know a lot of
people
it's really important to define her as a
lesbian
and yeah i'm not super particular about
what label she gets and i i think
if that's something that people can
relate to and that
what she went through then
if that's the label they want to put on
her that's fine i think there's an
also i think oz is a very important
relationship
yeah i think her you know
sort of like kissy fling with xander
also should be mentioned um but it is
true
that once she hit college i don't think
even in the comic book she ever
dated men again well i mean kennedy's
still alive so she's still with her in
the comics
at least as far as i got yeah
um not a kennedy fan um but
it is interesting with willow that
because
because
i'm kind of with you in that that
once she experienced that with tara she
realized
oh this is this this is something
else above and beyond what i had even
with oz even though that relationship
was important that this is something
else and so i
don't have a problem with her because
she does self-identify terms as
being a difference being a lesbian
i certainly don't have a problem with
herself identifying i do
get some fans frustration though in that
it does in some way to say well she's
gay
does in some way negate
oz or devalue him um
and it would have been nice i mean given
the given when it
aired it wasn't reasonable to expect
this but it would have been nice if
there could have been some conversation
along the way
about you know
how firmly she feels that she is gay
versus bisexual
but again given when it aired i'm not
sure that was a conversation we could
reasonably have ever expected to happen
i also have her down as the well
if it had been a different time and it
had been a less
repressed society at character wise
would they just would we just define
them as
lesbian or would they not have had any
relationships with men
okay so that's what that's like willow
and
um the two women and carol okay okay
yeah
um because again that was a very
repressed time
and i honestly their relationships with
men
are not healthy or very functional but i
think no
they're very much in love with each
other and celie
on the color purple i would say is i
would define as lesbian because again
very very awful sexual relationship with
a man
so um whereas i would define
shug as bisexual i wouldn't necessarily
define celia's
bisexual
i don't know if you have a category for
this what what are your feelings on
situations where it can not that we're
not necessarily the fiction itself
says this but it can be read as
any same-sex encounters were sort of
forced by circumstances
so for lack of a present for lack of a
better term
they're prison gay they're
they're together because there's no
opposite gender of
available option so that would come up
in something like oz
or it comes up it not it does come a bit
i feel like there's a bit of a situation
yeah
that with one not all the characters
definitely not all the characters
but there's a couple characters where
i'm like yeah or the one that really
frustrates me
um when i talk about wonder woman people
will say well obviously she was with a
woman when she was on the island that
i'm saying yes but
ever since she met steve trevor she's
only ever been depicted as
having any interest in men in the comics
which to me reads if she had any
relationships with women prior to that
it's because that was literally her only
option
which is why it really frustrates me
when people do it oh no she's queer i'm
like
i i feel like that's a stretch yeah
until we get a post leaving the island
canonical
lesbian relationship out of her oh you
know what we need to address is the
luke cage characters too
yeah um so season two of luke cage
shades and i forget the other guy oh i
don't remember him
either i don't either but that one i
actually felt was interesting because i
feel like
they tried to rationalize it
as being basically prison gay
but then when they both got out there
was still something there
yeah and i think that was part of what
made that a really interesting
relationship between those two because
they didn't expect these feelings to
linger once they were out that also does
a good job of really looking at
it's it's about more than just sex
yes the emotional connection and the
romantic
relationship which i think is important
but also i think because there's this
whole like
hedonistic promiscuity aspect and trope
going on
you have you lose
the importance of the romance sometimes
and the emotional connection
and sometimes like i
to me it's very clear that ruth and edgy
are in a relationship
so fry green tomatoes fried green
tomatoes
and like it's it's it's
more heavily implied in the book than in
the movie but
it's to me it is to read as anything
else
even in the movie even in the movie it's
heavily implied
but i think more important than whatever
they do
in their bed at night is their love and
their
their emotional connection they're just
their love for each other
and that's more clear i mean like that
is stated in a courtroom
like i love her she's my best friend and
i love her and
that to me is like pretty clear
but i get the frustration
where it's not made explicit and it's
like oh this is implied but no one ever
made this explicit and that does
that can feel like a form of erasure too
so that actually
makes me think of something kind of
interesting which is that i cannot
think off the top of my head at least
of very many representations of a
bisexual character
where they were shown to have romantic
interests in both men and women the
focus is pretty much
always on the sexual attraction and if
there is a romantic interest
it's almost evil it's almost always
heavily weighted
well usually on the same sex side when
i'm thinking of it
with the implication being that you know
the other is
either like with something like carol
circumstance you kind of have to
or what have you but i can't think of
too many instances where
it's where characters are shown to be
probably biromantic
as well as bisexual mm-hmm
[Music]
and to be clear i don't i think idri is
a lesbian
i don't think she's bisexual i think
ruth is probably bisexual in that really
no
that that's worth clarifying yeah to
clarify that because
in the implant category i like to also
add eleanor from the good place
i mean like she does she does she's
never pointing out how hot tahani is she
points that out
and i think there's been a couple other
comments about like
women she finds attractive and stuff and
like
it's i feel like it's pretty clearly
implied i said
like i don't think you would not be you
have not been paying attention for three
seasons if you're kind of like
what i said you got the hots for some
women there don't you
i think what i really like about it is
how casual it is like she
like because she herself and she's not
like weird like oh this is weird she's
just like oh yeah
and i kind of kind of just it's big i
like how
chill she is with it it is very in
keeping with her character
and it's also kind of keeping with her
character that she's like
i'm not gonna put this label on myself
and be like
you know yep just she's gonna say when
she finds someone hot or whatever she's
thinking
it's gonna come out of her mouth yeah
that's kind of who she is
and i i'm okay with it so i
get the frustration with it being
implied but some of the
the category some of the characters i'm
putting into this i'm like they're
i actually really like these roles and
these characters so
i mean i think where implied i mean
i was going to say where frustration is
more legitimate i don't want to
invalidate anyone's frustration when
they aren't quite getting the
representation they feel they deserve
that's i'm never going to say that's not
valid
but i i feel like where i kind of
personally
get it more is when it feels like it's
implied
um in in a way that is just
like it's implying it for the sake of
one of the bad reasons that we mentioned
it's implying it because it implies a
hedonism or it implies a promiscuity
or it implies it's going to just be a
phase
or or it implies it's a phase which we
haven't even gotten to yet
um or or it you know um it implies
they're just messing with somebody like
you're doing it like as a means yeah i
think
if you can imagine if you imply it but
that
but the nature of the implied
bisexuality doesn't automatically feed
into another negative trope
i don't think it's an inherently bad
thing to imply but not make explicit and
i say that as someone who has called out
things in the past for not being
explicit
but again with something like fried
green tomatoes like
okay yeah they never flat out say it but
how else do you
read that living together for years like
i
and people are like they should have
made it more explicit i'm like they kiss
at one point
and like the point with them too again
is not the sex
that movie is not it is about female
relationships and emotional connections
it's not at all about sex
yeah and and like and something like
that to
to have a sex scene would be distracting
it would be like
what is it doing in this movie a sex
scene with
any of the characters yeah yeah like and
so
i the criticism for that movie and again
it was like
an 89 90 when it was made like you're
not it was
pretty solid for when it came out yeah
um
there is and kind of and
sort of related to this category is the
and this is a criticism of some people
but sometimes i'm like
yeah they don't label themselves as
bisexual but it's pretty clear they're
bisexual
and i would say like sarah lance on
legends has never said hey i'm bisexual
as far as i know i haven't seen the
current season
she also doesn't have to because she
does explicitly have relationships
there clinda also falls into that
category
um so yeah it's pretty clear kalinda is
having relationships with both
men and women on the good life so and
actually that's that's worth pointing
out you
you don't have to say the word in order
to make it clear that it's the case
though i also i understand why it's so
important
for some people to have that word used
well here's what i would say
if they are using every word except that
which i think is the case in orange is
the new black
because they're literally talking about
a character's sexuality and they use
every word except bisexual
which is demonstrably what she is
that i feel you are well within your
rights to call out
but with someone like sarah lance from
legends of tomorrow
yes they don't say the word bisexual but
they also don't say the word straight
and they don't say the word gay
they just demonstrate they just
demonstrate through action
so the fact that they don't say that
word i think is balanced out by the fact
that well they're not labeling her with
any other ones
either they're just showing you what she
is and if you don't know what to call
that
then you're not paying attention
yeah um yeah and that's kind of how i
feel about calendar too i'm like yeah
she probably
never late she might not have labeled
herself as that but it's pretty clear
yeah i don't think it could be there are
several scenes where i'm like whoa they
put that on television
and i'm like yup yeah it's clear
it's clear
so you you mentioned it's a phase so
that has happened uh i
sex in the city is not fun when you talk
about
like especially bisexuality because you
have that
horrible quote from carrie the like
bisexuality is like a i think it's like
a stopover to gay town or something
like that it's it's cringe-worthy um
yeah and like i
the samantha i don't necessarily have
it's bad too
i was gonna say i don't necessarily have
a problem with somebody saying that if
if if they were proven wrong by the end
of that
storyline and she's not
i also feel like that whole marissa on
the oc
thing they i remember watching these
episodes and being like really
this is the least convincing thing ever
like
yeah neither one of these actresses
is that they're in a real relationship
and i'm like
nope i feel like the it's a phase thing
is something we don't
see actively anymore but will be tossed
off as like
a line so like you won't see something
like what we saw in sex and city where
we actually see a character do this
and then and then go oh that was a phase
but i think what we will still get is a
character offhandedly going
oh yeah yeah this happened back in
college
i went through a phase which is
dismissive and frustrating but
i mean and i wish that would go away too
but i feel like that's slightly less
egregious than
actually demonstrating look at this
phase having gone to an all-women's
college we did actually have terms for
you know we had luck which is lesbian
until graduation and we had bug which is
bisexual until graduation so
yes those are those lovely acronyms
yo if it wasn't if it wasn't trademark i
would so do the the more you know
thing right right across the screen
right now there's
there's two acronyms for you yeah it was
yeah which
again was like i did not like those i
did
uh i don't know but well and the other
thing is
i think what's frustrating is
there is some legitimacy to the idea
that someone experiments and it doesn't
stick
now calling it a phase still feels like
the wrong
the wrong way to put it but like a level
of experimentation
is legitimate i don't want to say like
you can't depict that because that is
some people's reality
but i do feel like
the majority of times it gets depicted
in anything it is done
very much in a way that is oh look at
this thing that was done briefly
it's like it's something you've tried on
yeah and it's it's
it's never it it doesn't it feels
shallow kind of
yeah and it feel it and it's one of
those things where you have to
where you have to kind of ask who
who is needing stronger representation
right now
the people who tried it and then went
back to effectively being straight
i.e the best represented sexuality and
entertainment
or the people who are in fact bisexual i
think they kind of need it a bit more so
i don't want to negate anyone who
experimented but at the same time like
if we're saying who kind of needs the
boost
it's it's this side um
so i think the other category
i've covered most of them in my notes
um
so you also you've spent you spent the
last i don't know
hour or so um looking up your real life
clan i didn't spend that long
okay maybe i did um now we're going to
try and
frame this through the depictions of
these people although it is worth noting
because a number of them have had
um movies or books or whatever made
about them
and a lot of them you're like oh i
didn't know i didn't know
so like i feel like oftentimes
the fact that these some of these people
are bisexual gets
severely downplayed so
places where it's down played um frida
kahlo
yep um i'm trying to remember if there's
any implication of it in the movie
i actually never got around to seeing
that movie i was i haven't
seen it in years and years i it was not
really
emphasized if it was to my knowledge
william shakespeare yeah so
biggest example where yeah it's like the
best kept literary secret it's not if
you've actually
read his work it's not even a well-kept
secret
i forget which i forget which sonnet it
is several of the sonnets
okay not just one it's multiple of the
of his famous
love sonnets like it's
if you read them and you go and you're
like okay these are about women and
they're like i don't quite understand
these and if you just go
these are about a man yeah then all of a
sudden you're like oh
okay everything now this makes sense
there's several of them that are
absolutely about men and i
there have been the golden boy oh god
yeah um there have only
there have been a ton of depictions of
shakespeare throughout the years and a
bunch of different things and i can only
think of
one where his bisexuality is
acknowledged funnily enough at a doctor
who episode
you just kind of love that i do i do so
yeah there's a line
in the shakespeare code um
where they're they're like they're
rushing off
to go deal with what the problem is
because so it's the 10th doctor and
martha
with shakespeare i've not seen this
episode yet
so no i'm not going to it's it's an okay
episode it's not amazing
but um they're they're headed off and
he's shakespeare has been
flirting with martha for most of this
thing you know calling her
the you know this enchanting dark lady
and and
that sort of thing because that is
another because that's also in the
science
of the dark lady um but the the doctor
chastises him
look you can you can flirt later and uh
shakespeare looks at him and goes is
that a promise
and the doctor goes oh about a dozen
academics just punch the air
yes but like i think it's very tight i
will punch the air when i see that
i think it's very telling that the only
instance that i can think of and like
i mean we're not shakespeare's scholars
but we both know shakespeare decently we
we like thanks karen yeah
minor flashback we went we went to the
same private school for seventh and
eighth grade we were required to do a
10-page paper on shakespeare
in eighth grade in order to graduate um
but yeah this that's the only instance i
can think of and that's
frustrating yeah oh you've got freddie
mercury down
yes um so that is he's
debated in terms of he
a label for him that one actually might
be an interesting
one because so uh
two and obviously we're talking about
someone who has passed away so obviously
they're not around to give their own
voice
but what do you feel the depiction
and bohemian rhapsody was do you feel it
it was that he was
the depiction of the potential or that
he was gay
the depiction of bohemian rhapsody was
consistent with what the general
public understanding of him is which is
that
he was a gay man the film
may have depicted him as i would argue
by romantic
because i think it could be argued that
he was in love with what's her name mary
mary austin mary austin but it did
seem like they his sexual leanings
were very heavily towards men
now i really i
i i like that you put biromantic on him
because i
feel like there's almost she was such an
important role in his life and is such
an important person and a muse
and i really don't like
that i feel like sometimes she's almost
forgotten
yeah and i i think the movie depicted
that fairly well
but it is worth pointing out that a fair
number of people close to him including
members of his family have
said you know since his passing he
wasn't gay he was bisexual
but the public perception of him is
generally as a gay man
and the film more or less held to that
[Music]
yeah i like the idea that he's
biromantic yeah i think that's a good
label for him because of the importance
of his
relationship which was throughout his
life you know
yeah with mary so um but yes i would say
sexually he's definitely more leaning
towards men especially
you know once he was into his 20s pretty
yeah like late 20s or again that's
certainly how it was depicted in the
film
i noticed you have eleanor roosevelt
down there well i mean there are
a lot of i don't know the recent
depictions of her but she's probably at
least
she's another one we should at least
label as biromantic
yeah and i think i i don't know how many
movies have been made like strictly
about her i think she just has a
tendency to turn up in
other films or that are serious about
fda
that are about fdr or you know things so
i don't know how much
i or annie for some reason
oh yeah she is okay that's a weird movie
and probably not going to depict her
bisexuality in that one
probably not probably not um so
yeah and then you told me the rest that
but we would like to plug
we want this to happen please somebody
make a movie about josephine baker holy
crap yes
yes and if you don't know who that is
google is your friend
if you want to fully appreciate who that
is google
without safe search on is your friend
so you're welcome yeah um so
that that's our plug please make a movie
about josephine baker
um so can we can now talk about like
decent representation the good
all of this build up to get to the good
ones
yeah um so
and some of these we have talked on
because i know you've got you've got
sarah lance down there
but i feel overall um so yes
let's talk about the two i've i've
mentioned which is sarah lance on
legends
who i just love her sarah's great
love her relationship that she's in as
of the second to last season
yeah as of as of season three she's been
in that relationship
yeah although she had her one-off with
john constantine
who has who has yet to be depicted as
bisexual oh i think he has been in
the currency okay i i haven't gotten
through season four but as of season
three he had not yet
and in his own show was not depicted as
bisexual though he is in the comics
so if he actually if that gets confirmed
in season four of
legends that'll make me very happy i
have to catch up on it uh yes i'm
excited for that i'm excited for marcera
she's a lot of fun she might slightly
sometimes veer into a little i think
she's probably the most busy
of any of the legends in terms of yeah
because she has her one-offs with like
what what queen or queen guinevere
yeah i was gonna say there was some
queen she messed with one episode
there's been a couple guys here and
there so she's
she does slip into the promiscuous but i
mean in season three they're
establishing her
in a like solid relationship she yeah
she does
she settles down she settles down really
nicely i just love her
she's a great leader a compelling story
great story arc great great character
and there's rosa from brooklyn
yeah who again i i think it was like
ever so many people were delighted
with the episode where she came out um i
love the actress who plays her
and to my understanding she herself is
bisexual so like they've been consulting
her very closely whenever they
want to tackle that with her character
in the show
and they've been getting her input on
that i just love rosa as a character
she's just so
dry and tough that's wonderful she is
just so
scared so like if you have fun thing
because the
her coming out to the precinct that clip
is on youtube like
officially from the brooklyn nine-nine
youtube page it's not like pirated or
anything
and it's just her standing in front of
them i have something to say
i'm bisexual you now have 60 seconds to
ask me questions go
i wish i feel like a lot of people have
felt
you know at one point or another that
are you know
queer or gay or lesbian or
bisexual or transgendered at some point
we're like okay
fine ask us questions we know you have
them yeah
but she does it at the moment she does
it in the very rosa way of
basically saying you go past 60 seconds
and i'm gonna throw something at your
head
she doesn't have to say it they just
know it oh
so yes uh i love rosa love stephanie
beatrice who plays her
so happy um and
uh oh i see your name i'm excited about
down there
um well i'm gonna go to ambrose spellman
all right who
i on the first season of sabrina thought
he was gay because he's specifically in
a relationship with a man but then later
on he's depicted
um sort of having a relationship well
not a relationship but
um a night a night with a woman which is
kind of
orchestrated so i guess some people
might
still put him in the gay category but um
i think he's by i i'm guessing he's
bisexual
again it's not clearly defined i really
enjoy ambrose
um he is i mean
again he's on one of those supernatural
shows but i would not define him as
villainous
um i he's a
really great supporting character on
that show
um and again i mean there's some good
intersexual or intersexually
international
you knew that was gonna come out of my
mouth because we said
the word bisexual so intersectional
you can keep that in there i'm going to
oh i know
um i'm cutting my flubs i'm keeping
yours thanks
the representation in um
in media i mean and no there's not
enough
there is and we're going to discuss you
know where we need more representation
but there are some good examples
happening i think with him with rosa
um and just you know there's some
celebrities coming out where i'm like
yes
there are and like what the name you got
you have down there that i'm like
we have daryl on yeah crazy
ex-girlfriend
daryl he's so adorable he's really
adorable and white josh and they're
they're they're my favorite relationship
on crazy ex-girlfriend which
we should say that we are not we are
only part way through season two yes
with so like if you don't know what's
going on now if things go
pear-shaped please don't tell us i want
them together forever because they're so
cute
and daryl i mean daryl has a coming out
song about bisexuality what would be
better
that's it's great and it and it again
it's nice there because
it could have and not again not to
necessarily denigrate the willow thing
but it is nice as a counterpoint to
something like what happened with willow
which was
she starts relationship with women and
she goes yeah i'm gay
and daryl starts a relationship with a
man that is now
i am bisexual i will now sing a whole
song
about it it's not even like oh i'm gay's
like no i'm bi
i'm bi hey and his boyfriend his
boyfriend who is gay
like knows he's bi and yeah no cool yeah
it's so good it's so good he's so dorky
i love him
um apparently and we haven't gotten to
this yet valencia is also bisexual
really yep also later on in the show
i'll be curious to see how that is
because valencia is kind of awful
well so many people on the show and most
of the characters on the show
are kind of awful of villainous and more
like awful characters
daryl is by no means the worst
or like even top three four worst
characters on that show
no that that if you've never watched
crazy ice girlfriend
it's great but like it's a bit of a dark
show in that
the list of people who aren't kind of
garbage fire human beings
is the minority of the cast
and does include i really feel strongly
like
at the like good human beings i would
put white josh
white josh is at the top daryl comes in
under that
ah then there's there's a big gap after
that
yeah darryl daryl means well and
i mean he he's very socially awkward
sometimes
yeah but i think he's a pretty decent
human being
he tries a little too hard is the main
thing yeah
um so yeah um
those are some great examples that i've
talked about and there's others i've
heard about
um i guess
i had forgotten i had never gotten so i
had watched
um grey's anatomy the first two or three
seasons so there's a character
i've never seen it so oh my god and then
i kind of lost
interest in it so i never saw callie
come out but cali comes out as bisexual
and i guess that actress is now playing
another
character that came out as bisexual
recently and is herself bisexual so
awesomeness
i think her name is sarah or sorar
i think it might be pronounced ramirez
you know who i just remembered
that actually i need to vent about a bit
now okay go for it
did you ever watch house oh i know what
you're getting
13. oh yeah okay good no it's not
all right at all i used to love house
she's awesome
side note olivia wilde yeah
also played marissa's girlfriend on the
oc
oh boy she's double dipping into the
badness okay the
like not good bisexual representation so
like there was a big fundamental problem
with 13 as a character
which was that they gave her a very long
list of traits but never characterized
her
so like she was bisexual and she had a
drug problem and she had a terminal
illness and
like they just kept piling on stuff that
she never actually
got to just be a character because she
was always just
dealing with this identity of her yeah
so she never just got to be she never
just got to exist
and then her sexuality specifically
actually is really problematic because
she as a character because she's a very
unstable character
she is most stable when she's in a
relationship with a guy
and she has her at her least stable
when she is in relationships with women
to be fair i haven't gone back and
re-watched
these episodes in a long time so if my
memory of the timeline is slightly off
feel free to correct me but to my memory
like when she breaks up with
i forget his name um but when she breaks
up with the guy who
she was with and she immediately starts
seeing women again and doing drugs and
partying and like it it's
it links her her
time with women to her other worst
behaviors
i saw a couple episodes that she was on
but i never consistently watched house
like you did so i never got the like
i did all eight seasons full i'm sorry
no for someone for some of those it is
sorry yeah um yeah i have heard that
that character is pretty
problematic though that yeah so
okay get that one off my chest um
but i mean it is i think i feel like it
is worth pointing out
that i didn't neither of us like did a
number crunch for how frequently
bisexual characters tend to come up
it's gotten better so like back in 2014
i guess there's only eight bisexual
women on broadcast
prime time tv and two bisexual men and
it's
dramatically gone up each year that
being said
it's still disproportionately women
though still disproportionately women
and if you
look at you know gays lesbians
bisexuals the majority of
the depiction and the representation is
still gay men
yeah so we have we have a
proportionality
issue both in terms of doesn't reflect
reality yeah
both in terms of the gender of the
bisexual characters
and what percentage of the lesbian gay
bisexual
because i feel like in that conversation
transgender's over here because
gender identity and sexual preference
are not the same thing so you kind of
remove that from that
clumping a little bit um that there's
they're still underrepresented within
non-heterosexual relationships
definitely really under-represented yeah
it really god it really kind of is just
daryl right now isn't it
and ambrose oh yeah there's a couple
others um
uh side note and this is another
disturbing trend that's been on a couple
um
shows and i haven't seen it so much but
i've read a couple of things about it
is that bisexual men will be like
side characters that the main character
is dating and it like freaks out the
women
that they're dating someone bisexual and
that's happened a couple times
recently on shows and so i'm just like
oh no
oh boy so we definitely need to make
headway in terms of bisexual ones so
it's a slow process
um you know and i feel like
the bisexual erasure is still a major
issue and i have friends you know who
are
bisexual and married or in a significant
relationship with a man for like years
and years and they
you know they feel like the world won't
acknowledge them as bisexual they it
won't like yeah you know
they and people you know like within our
community are just like no
you're not bisexual or really you are
yeah
you're married to a man how can you be
bisexual
very easily i feel like in some way
that's part of what
brought about the promiscuity trope it
it's like
you have to keep reaffirming no they
like both so you have to keep
showing them we do otherwise you get
like the willow thing where oh well now
they're just with this so now we'll just
call them gay
or we'll just call them straight and so
like
in an odd way the promiscuity thing
while not good and problematic
does kind of serve a function to
continually reiterate
that they do have an attraction to both
i it's annoying that that would even be
necessary
that said i feel like over the course of
this conversation a lot of the tropes
that are the worst
we see fewer and fewer and fewer of as
we get pressed
closer to the present like because most
of the examples that
like things like the femme fatale
bisexual villain
that's that's i can't remember the last
time i saw that done
like legitimately like unironically i
cannot remember the last time because
there is definitely some irony in
barbara keane
yeah barbara keane is i mean gotham is a
it is a dark show but it's a camp show
it is a campy show
and i would not call barbara keane a a
straightforward depiction of anything no
to be honest
she's too much fun yeah yeah yeah
uh so but like i cannot remember the
last time i saw it done
legitimately and even with things like
the promiscuity i feel like
even that gets dialed back it has been
slowly dialing back
so i feel like i feel like things are
overall trending in a better direction
but as you said
you know we've still got a lot of issues
in terms of proportionality and
things like that so there's absolute
headway to be made
but i feel like most of the most
egregious stuff
we're doing better yeah we have is
easing a lot of words yeah
to do but and especially like i'd love
to see more depictions of bisexual men
but and not the ones we're getting were
their side characters and it's
an issue with women i would love more
ambroses and more daryl's
um that would make me oh the world
the world needs more debt i don't know
ambrose but the world needs more daryl's
absolutely
yep so i think they will wrap it up
there
yeah so thank you yeah you're welcome i
finally
did this
but i i was i was excited to be able to
i mean i like having you on anyways
but i was excited to be able to have you
on for one of the representation
discussions and i i didn't know if you
would
want to be that open with it and i was
i'm glad you didn't
i mean like nice people i know you're
not closeted but obviously this is a
this is a bit this is a bit like my
parents know yes it's
yeah doing this is a bit like getting on
a bull horn though
strange but yeah i appreciate it it's
it's who i am so you know
[Laughter]
so uh yeah we're gonna wrap it up there
and uh
whatever your folks thoughts are on
bisexual representation the best the
worst is it getting better
whatever your thoughts are and i just
always be respectful
i've had it i had an issue having to
actually explain to someone look i don't
care why you started doing personal
attacks i would clear out your comments
so don't do that but if you can manage
to not do that drop your thoughts down
in the comments
and let's talk about it uh there's a
whole bunch of stuff to do because you
can hit the like button
or subscribe or support me on patreon or
also none of it you don't have to
because at the end of the day
you're the council i just run the
meetings sometimes with liz
help and until next time this council
is adjourned
thank you baby and when
i'm on i run the meetings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you